The idea that you're gonna do something
that you're not used to doing, simply
to develop your writing skills,
I don't think is that practical?
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here
again, and today I want to talk
about writing, writing in the
language that you are learning.
Remember, if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications,
and if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
So I sometimes get asked like,
okay, Steve, you always talk
about input, reading, listening,
building up your vocabulary.
Uh, and even you talk about the importance
of speaking and speaking a lot, at
least once you have enough vocabulary.
But what about writing?
How do we improve our writing?
And I recognize that writing can
be a way of improving your ability
in the language, a way of getting
to more output in the language.
And for some people it's important
to their academic aspirations,
professional aspirations.
So what do I have to say
on the subject of writing?
Well, first of all, I would
divide it into two sort of stages.
Okay.
On the one hand, if you are
at an early stage in your, you
know, learning of a particular
language, how do you use writing?
How do you get to writing?
And the second issue is if you are already
fairly proficient in the language, how
do you improve your ability to write,
you know, academic papers or professional
correspondence or things of that nature?
So first of all, with regard to using
writing at an early stage in learning
the language, first of all, as I say
about all output activities, you have
to have enough of the language in you.
So you have to do a lot
of reading and listening.
And as I mentioned many times in the
early stages, listen to what you read.
Read what you listen to.
Have the two of them sort of work
with each other to build up your
familiarity with the language.
You have to have that within
you so that you can then output.
So when you start to output in the
language, writing actually has a number
of advantages compared to speaking.
First of all, when you are speaking,
you tend to use words that you're
confident that you can use.
Uh, you're reluctant to use words where
you're not sure what the word means.
You're reluctant to use structures
that you're not very confident
that you can really control
those structures, those patterns.
Whereas when you write you've
got all the time in the world.
You can look up words, you can
look up, you know, the conjugation.
You can look up different tenses,
tenses, different structures.
So you can actually experiment using
words and, and phrases that you
might not remember to use or feel
confident using when you're speaking.
So writing is a great way to improve
your ability to output in the language.
Another thing I would say is develop the
habit of making your writing and speaking
as close to each other as possible.
What I mean by that is whenever I
have learned the language, I try
not to have a very casual form of
the language and then have some kind
of a more, uh, you know, stylized
form of, of writing in the language.
When I go to write, it's a
continuation of my speaking.
So I, I wanna have my speaking as
logical and as neutral as possible
so that I can use that when I write.
Even though I know that in languages
like Chinese, uh, French, there
is a stylized form of the written
language, but I don't use that.
And I know that in every language there's
a very slangy form of the language.
I don't use that.
I try to have a neutral form of the
language, that way when I speak, and
as I develop my speaking ability, I'm
also developing my writing ability,
and as I use my writing to improve
my ability to express myself, I can
bring that back into my speaking.
So try to make your writing and speaking
as closely connected as possible.
So all of these are ways to get to output.
What should we write about?
Obviously there are people who say,
well, you should keep a diary, but I
have never kept a diary and therefore it
would be very unnatural for me to keep
a diary in the language I'm learning.
I'm unlikely to do it.
I might start but I won't continue.
So the idea that you're gonna do
something that you're not used to
doing, simply to develop your writing
skills, I don't think is that practical.
So if you can develop a correspondence
with someone where you're sending
emails back and forth, uh, but
you're still trying to not use the
sort of, you know, Twitteries or
"gonna" "wanna" type of English, Try
to keep it fairly neutral, fairly
standard, and correspond with people.
Then those are writing
exchanges that are meaningful.
If you like to keep a diary, by all
means, keep a diary, but it's not
personally something that I would do.
Now, once we move to sort of developing an
ability to write better for a professional
or academic purpose, you have to go
after the model of, of what you want
to be able to do with your writing.
So you have to find a lot of
material of the style that you want.
Of the vo, which has the vocabulary
that you want to use and, and not just
the sort of technical vocabulary, but
also the way thoughts are introduced.
You know, on the one hand, on the other
hand, Uh, there are ways that our thoughts
are introduced in writing that can be
a little more formal than in speaking.
So go find this kind of
content, import it into LingQ.
I would even combine listening
with reading because when you hear
the same content spoken, it helps
to basically, you know, those
turns of phrases into your brain.
So as I said, uh, I'm not, I
haven't been active writing in
the languages that I'm learning.
Uh, and that has been the case throughout,
uh, including Persian right now.
However, uh, I was reminded that
there is a feature at LingQ which
helps people who do want to write.
So I thought I would have a look at that.
And show you how that works.
So if I go to the community page, there
is a thing called the writing exchange.
So if I click on the writing exchange,
then I will see that people here
have submitted, um, writing, which
the members are correct for them.
And, uh, so if we look at this, we can
see that, uh, in the case here of this
French one, someone has replied and
you'll see that someone has volunteered
to, uh, correct the writing in French.
In fact, there were two different ... So
you can look at two different versions of,
of the correction, all of which I think
for people who are interested in writing.
This is quite good.
Here's one in Polish, and here again, this
person has corrected the Polish writing,
so I think that's a good thing to do.
You can correct other people's
writing in your native language.
The biggest question for me is what
am I gonna write about and, uh, I
think, uh, if, uh, there is sort
of genuine correspondence, then
the writing becomes meaningful.
Otherwise, if you, uh, are prepared
to, um, you know, keep, uh, a
diary, then that would be a way
of, of, uh, getting you to write.
Just curious.
I haven't been here, but if I look
at, um, you know, my statistics,
I hadn't realized this, but I can,
I can look at how I compared to
taking a while to come up here.
How I compare.
So in terms of all time LingQs,
I am the second most active
person in Persian on our website.
If I look at known words,
I'm in third place.
Uh, that's for all time.
However, if I look at the last, uh, three
months, then I'm well down the list.
Uh, other people have
been more active than me.
I gotta be somewhere.
I'm number 10.
Anyway, one of the things I find
interesting in LingQ is that I don't
use all the features, but one of the
features that, uh, people could use who
are interested in writing and having
the writing corrected, and it is free, I
believe maybe there's an exchange of coins
and you just go to the writing exchange,
which can be found at the community.
So, uh, I hope that is useful and uh, if
I do get going on writing in Persian, Uh,
I think I'll probably use the sort of,
uh, scrambled sentence or, uh, you know,
integrated review functionality that is
now available on, uh, on, uh, iOS and
will soon be available on all platforms
as a way of starting to compose to some
extent in the language that I'm learning.
So lots of reading, lots of listening and
then just, you know, try to, if you have
to write professionally, then you will
have a real reason to write professionally
and, and when you write, the, the other
issue that comes up beyond this question
of, you know, vocabulary and phrasing
is, how do I structure my, you know,
essay or whatever it is I have to write?
And here again, what I would suggest
is in every language there are sort
of manuals on how to write well, how
to organize your thoughts, essays
for school or whatever it might be.
And I would go and find those, uh,
manuals on how to write and how to
express yourself in the target language.
And then I would bring those into LingQ.
Then I would learn from these so that
not only am I improving my language, but
I'm also learning the different forms
of, you know, collecting your thoughts.
Uh, I studied in France.
In France, they have a very specific
way of organizing thoughts at
Science Po, we had to have sort of
introduction, part one, part two.
Part one had section A, B, part two had
section A, B, then there was a conclusion.
So that was their format.
But there are many different formats
and these formats can vary from
culture or from language to language.
So I would suggest that when you're at
that sort of a more sophisticated level
and you wanna improve your writing, go and
find these manuals in the target language.
Study them at lingQ, learn the words and
phrases, and along the way you'll learn
how in those languages and cultures,
they want you to organize your thoughts.
Okay, well, there you have it.
I wanna leave you with two videos that
I did quite a few years ago also on the
subject of writing, and I think you might
find that my views have changed a little
bit or maybe they haven't changed so
much, but they might be useful reference.
Thank you for listening.